scp-682 vs scp-3660  when the scp foundation tested  scp-3660 the zoo zipper a zipper that  hollows creatures out and turns their  insides into an animal against scp-682  the hard-to-destroy reptile they were  hoping to minimize the monster the  zipper was placed against the creature  while it slept and left in place within  seven minutes it did its thing unzipping  682 and turning its body into dead  rubber only a tiny gecko with 682's mind  came out of the mess confused and angry  researcher gentler entered the  containment chamber and stomped on the  682 gecko sadly this didn't work out the  682 gecko suddenly became 682's regular  size while still retaining its gekko  appearance and ate researcher jetler  before breaching containment and killing  several more people 682 returned to its  normal appearance over the next two  weeks test failed